pokud otočíš míč kolem jedné osy a pak kolem druhé, není to stejné jako provést tato dvě otočení v opačném pořadí
dnes v Kiskit in the Classroom uvidíme, co má tento míč společného s kvantovými počítači a jedním z nejslavnějších
principů kvantové mechaniky – principem neurčitosti
vítej v Kiskit in the Classroom, sérii videí, kde rozebíráme základní koncepty, se kterými se
můžeš setkat v kurzu zaměřeném na kvantové výpočty. Každé video je doprovázeno interaktivním modulem odkazovaným v
popisu níže, takže se na něj určitě podívej. Dnes mluvíme o Heisenbergově principu neurčitosti. Pokud
jsi o něm už slyšel, možná znáš i starý vtip o Heisenbergovi. Jednou byl zastaven při řízení a policista se ho zeptal:
Víš, jak rychle jsi jel? Heisenberg odpověděl: Ne, ale přesně vím, kde jsem. To je zhruba
Heisenbergův princip neurčitosti ve zkratce – nemůžeš zároveň znát polohu a hybnost částice
s dokonalou přesností. Často se zapisuje takto: Delta x krát Delta p je větší nebo
rovno h/2, kde Delta X a Delta P jsou
nejistoty v poloze a hybnosti a H je malá fundamentální konstanta v kvantové mechanice.
Heisenberg přišel s touto nerovností v roce 1927, když si představoval, jak změřit polohu elektronu. Pokud
od něj odrazíš foton, abys zjistil, kde je, tento foton nevyhnutelně kopne do elektronu a naruší jeho
hybnost. Nejde jen o tvrzení o tom, že měření narušuje systém – říká nám to, že existují fundamentální
limity toho, kolik toho o přírodě můžeme zjistit. Toto je jeden příklad širšího principu zvaného komplementarita, který
říká, že určité aspekty přírody jsou navzájem neslučitelné a nelze je pozorovat
zároveň. Například kvantové objekty se někdy chovají jako částice a někdy jako vlny,
ale nemůžeš pozorovat oba způsoby chování zároveň. Heisenbergův vztah polohy a hybnosti pokrývá jen jeden z
mnoha souborů komplementárních vlastností. Tato inherentní neurčitost souvisí s tím, jak vnímáme vlastnosti jako
poloha a hybnost v kvantové mechanice. Místo toho, abychom přemýšleli o X a P jako o proměnných nebo vnitřních vlastnostech,
které každá částice má, jsou v kvantové mechanice poloha a hybnost operátory. Nejsou to vlastnosti
systému, ale věci, které se systémem můžeš provádět. Zjistit polohu částice teď vyžaduje, abys provedl
operaci na tomto systému a provedl měření. Tato operace může ovlivnit výsledek dalších následných
operací. Jako analogii si představ kus suchého dřeva. Má mnoho vlastností, jako je
poloha, velikost, tvar. Má také vlastnost hořlavosti a plovatelnosti ve vodě. Kdyby bylo toto dřevo
kvantový objekt, nebyly by to vlastnosti, o kterých bys mohl jen tak vědět předem. Místo toho říkáme, že jsou to
pozorovatelné – věci, o kterých se můžeš dozvědět, pokud na systém aplikuješ nějakou operaci. Musel bys tedy aplikovat
operátor hořlavosti nebo plovatelnosti, což by vyžadovalo skutečně zkusit dřevo zapálit nebo ho dát do
vody, abys zjistil, zda plave. Výsledek každého z těchto operátorů závisí na pořadí, ve kterém je aplikuješ. Pokud
nejprve otestuješ hořlavost, dřevo shoří na popel a nebudeš moci otestovat, zda plave. Ale pokud nejprve otestuješ
plovatelnost, bude příliš mokré na to, aby shořelo. Říkáme, že operátory hořlavosti a
plovatelnosti nekomutují – na pořadí operací záleží. To vede k fundamentálnímu
limitu toho, jak dobře lze tyto dvě pozorovatelné o kusu dřeva znát, protože nemůžeme s jistotou říci, zda je
hořlavé nebo plovatelné, aniž bychom znali kontext tohoto měření. Samozřejmě s opravdovým kusem dřeva
bys ho mohl přeřezat napůl a otestovat obě vlastnosti zároveň, ale s kvantovou částicí tak udělat nemůžeš. Tato
analogie se dřevem je jen analogií – neurčitost je čistě kvantová záležitost. X a P také nekomutují
a tato vlastnost nekomutování vede k Heisenbergovu principu neurčitosti. Obecně platí, že jakékoli dva operátory,
které nekomutují, budou mít svůj vlastní princip neurčitosti. Obecnou formu principu neurčitosti lze
zapsat takto: Delta A krát Delta
B je větší nebo rovno
1/2 násobku absolutní hodnoty A a B, kde
tato závorka se nazývá
komutátor a rovná se rozdílu mezi aplikací nejprve A a pak
B a aplikací nejprve B a pak A. Tyto ostré závorky
signalizují, že počítáš takzvanou střední hodnotu toho, co je uvnitř. Zhruba řečeno, pokud bys provedly totéž
měření mnohokrát, střední hodnota je průměrná hodnota všech těchto měření. Dnes
skutečně otestujeme a ověříme tento princip neurčitosti na IBM kvantovém počítači. Podíváme se na tři různé
pozorovatelné qubit, ukážeme, že jejich operátory nekomutují, a pak budeme schopni dokázat, že
princip neurčitosti platí pro tyto qubit pozorovatelné. Nejprve krátká odbočka o užitečném způsobu, jak vizualizovat kvantový
stav qubit. Může být reprezentován vektorem ukazujícím někam na sféru zvanou Blochova sféra. Probíral jsem
to v předchozím videu, které je odkazováno v popisu, ale dám ti tu rychlé shrnutí. Tady je
Blochova sféra. Každý vektor je parametrizován dvěma úhly: Theta a Phi.
Stav nula je na severním pólu a stav jedna je na jižním pólu. Stejná superpozice 0 a 1 je
někde podél rovníku, kde Phi se rovná relativní fázi mezi dvěma částmi
superpozice. Takže tento stav by se rovnal
1/odmocnina(2) krát 0 plus e na i Phi krát 1, kde Phi je ta
fáze. Když měříme pozorovatelnou qubit, výsledek je vždy jedna ze dvou možností odpovídajících dvěma
možným stavům qubit. Pro experiment, který se chystáme provést, se podíváme na tři pozorovatelné a
jejich odpovídající operátory X, Y a Z. Když měříš kteroukoli z těchto pozorovatelných, dostaneš buď plus jedna nebo
minus jedna s pravděpodobností, která závisí na úhlu mezi vektorem qubit na Blochově sféře a
WEBVTT
osou měření. Jak bys mohl čekat, Z měří podél osy Z, X podél X
a Y podél Y. Teď si vzpomeň, že mluvíme o pozorovatelných, protože u kvantového
systému už nemůžeš jen tak znát věci o systému, aniž bys je měřil.
A každá pozorovatelná má odpovídající operaci, protože měření vyžadují operace. Nemusí to být zřejmé, ale
ukazuje se, že operace – operátory – odpovídající každé z těchto pozorovatelných x, y a z jsou
rotace o Pi kolem jejich příslušných os. Takže X je rotace kolem X, Y
kolem Y a Z kolem Z. Abychom zjistili, zda tyto operátory komutují, můžeme ověřit, zda rotace
na sféře komutují. Pokud ano, princip neurčitosti se neuplatní a mohli bychom znát X, Y a Z qubit
s dokonalou přesností. Pokud nekomutují, budeme schopni najít nový vztah neurčitosti pro qubit. Sleduj
bod na tomto míči, když otáčím nejprve kolem X a pak kolem Y – skončí
tady. Teď to zkusme v opačném pořadí: otáčím nejprve kolem Y a
pak kolem X – skončí tamhle. Takže jasně nekomutují. To znamená,
že nemůžeme zároveň znát přesné hodnoty X, Y a Z qubit – budeme mít
vztah neurčitosti. Přeskočíme detaily, ale skončíme se třemi různými vztahy
neurčitosti: Delta X krát Delta Y
je větší nebo rovno |⟨Z⟩|, Delta Y krát Delta Z je větší nebo rovno
|⟨X⟩| a Delta Z krát Delta X je větší nebo rovno
|⟨Y⟩|. Takže součin libovolných dvou neurčitostí je vždy větší nebo
roven střední hodnotě třetí pozorovatelné. Pojďme použít Qiskit, abychom viděli, co se
stane, když se pokusíme měřit Z i X stavu nula. Měření Z je snadné – jde o takzvanou standardní bázi
kvantového počítače. Měření jsou vždy podél Z jako výchozí. Ale pro měření X potřebujeme provést něco, co se nazývá
změna báze – v podstatě otočení Blochovy sféry tak, aby X nyní ukazovalo nahoru tam, kde dřív ukazovalo Z. K tomu
použijeme Hadamard gate. Celý kvantový circuit tedy bude vypadat takto: měříme v Z, aplikujeme Hadamard
a pak měříme v X. Pokud použijeme Qiskit Primitive Sampler ke spuštění tohoto experimentu mnohokrát, skončíme
s histogramem výsledků měření, který pro Z vypadá takto
a pro měření v X takto. Jak vidíš, změřili jsme
qubit ve stavu nula podél Z s téměř stoprocentní jistotou, ale
podél X jsme o stavu qubit v podstatě nic nevěděli – byl změřen jako nula nebo jedna se stejnou
pravděpodobností, což znamená, že naše neurčitost v X byla tak velká, jak jen může být. To nám dává
určitou představu o tomto kompromisu neurčitostí, ale na našem kvantovém počítači to dokážeme trochu lépe. Můžeme použít
Qiskit Primitive zvaný Estimator k nalezení středních hodnot našich pozorovatelných X, Y a Z a
neurčitosti v každé z nich. Zkusme to pro stav ukazující ve směru plus X na Blochově sféře. Použijeme Estimator
k výpočtu neurčitostí v X a Z pro tento stav a střední hodnoty
Y. S tímto stavem dostaneme z Qiskit tento výsledek. Když vezmeme součin dvou
neurčitostí v X a Y, vidíme, že je, jak se očekávalo, větší než absolutní
hodnota střední hodnoty Y. Ale tohle bylo jen pro jeden konkrétní stav – chceme se ujistit, že tato nerovnost
platí pro všechny stavy qubit. Použijeme tedy Estimator znovu, ale tentokrát ho požádáme, aby prošel hodnotami
parametru a našel střední hodnoty při každé hodnotě parametru, kterou mu dáme. Parametr, přes který chceme
procházet, je úhel Theta na Blochově sféře, abychom ověřili nerovnost pro všechny stavy qubit ležící na
tomto oblouku procházejícím rovinou XZ. Když to uděláme, dostaneme graf jako funkci úhlu Theta. Červená
křivka je součin dvou neurčitostí a oranžová křivka je střední hodnota Y. Jak se očekávalo,
součin neurčitostí v X a Z je mnohem vyšší než střední hodnota Y. Ale nebylo to
příliš těžké splnit nerovnost, protože střední hodnota Y byla tak nízká – byla nulová pro všechny stavy na
tomto oblouku. Udělejme podobné procházení hodnotami Theta, ale místo roviny XZ nastavíme Phi rovno pi/
4, takže se díváme na stavy qubit ležící na jiném oblouku na sféře. Zde vidíme, že nerovnost je
testována trochu více, protože oranžová a červená křivka jsou blíže k sobě, ale červená je vždy nad oranžovou
a princip neurčitosti stále platí. Ještě jsme nezkontrolovali všechny stavy, ale doufám, že už začínáš chápat
myšlenku. Existuje fundamentální nepoznatelnost jakýchkoli dvou komplementárních aspektů kvantového
systému, včetně tohoto qubit, který jsme používali. Princip neurčitosti nás nutí čelit faktu, že bez ohledu na to,
jak moc se snažíme, bez ohledu na to, jak chytrá jsou naše měření, nikdy nebudeme vědět vše s dokonalou přesností.
Není z toho úniku. Pokud mi nevěříš – nebo i když věříš – vyzývám tě: podívej se na modul
odkazovaný v popisu a zkus princip neurčitosti překonat. Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště.